great yeah I got it I date a little bit
you know here and there if there's the
right suitor around so typically when
I'm looking for somebody I'm interested
in they just have to be sweet comes down
to sweetness I am actually a super picky
ear if somebody like totally different
food for me I would learn to love it or
maybe I would transition them to my ways
but like if they gave me food I would
eat it I'm a presuming we're going to be
pretty opposite but maybe we'll be
pretty similar I'm just excited to eat
I'm starving I'm not dating anybody
right now but I'm trying to date I like
meeting people in person I try the apps
it didn't feel right I like someone is
no engage I think you have to have some
things in common right you have
somewhere to start from by the same time
he's also good to be open to new
experiences the only things that I don't
eat is like onions and pickles I am
nervous a little bit because I don't
know what the other person picked for me
but I'm a little excited because it will
be a surprise that's the fun of it I'm
Avalon hi I'm one how are you good you
look better than I expected
are you excited I'm very excited are you
kidding me like for you for me a
potential snack and then for the snack
they're really a really nice voice thank
you so here we have Famous Amos bite
size chocolate chip cookies delicious
and I'm not quite sure how nutritious
yeah I think you get them for that they
look good I like a good chocolate chip
actually chocolate chip cookies are my
favorite really yeah I think me too no
joke cuz they're just simply delicious
okay up next we have Haribo gummy bears
which I agree with this is for the wind
yes I'm glad gummy bears are like my
favorite candy I started eating them
with my family when I was younger me and
my brother food five for the yellow and
the transparent ones which one is your
favorite I know I don't like the clear
ones cuz he's funny
I like the yellow ones or the orange
ones okay well let's move on to the
savory aspect we have Gordon veggie
strong I was eating too many like chips
and the readers and other stuff that was
not that healthy so I try to go for a
healthier option and I found those okay
we have it looks like the final treat
and I know what these are but I don't
know how to say them for rare Roe Roe
share now these are delicious so
delicious
yeah I'm addicted to chocolate chopped
like I eat chocolate like every day I'm
addicted we got we got an addiction
together well thank you for sharing your
treats goodness oh my pleasure I'm glad
you like them I was a little afraid you
got good taste awesome thanks I'm
feeling like you're a super like
family-oriented person and you enjoy
sentimental things so this is like
actually a great sign all right Wow what
is all this I haven't seen some of these
at all this is Annie's homegrown organic
bunny fruit snacks
they feel like gummies I'm a fiend for
gummies my vitamins are gummies
everything's coming so like I'm bad with
chocolate you're bad with gummy yes
gotcha I completely understand the
addiction all right what's next we have
endangered species chocolate oh that's
already so nice Bob silky dark chill oh
my god I love this
I'm actually like kinda excited to try
this all right next is Amy's organics
organic coconut cookies and peanut
butter I don't know how this will mix
together never try this before it's like
the coconut is the base and then the
peanut butter is a flavor so it's not
really coconutty but it's peanut buttery
I feel bad now you're like everything my
my snacks were like nowadays everything
is like so healthy and these are the
oven baked parm crisps oh it's so yummy
so these are like she's next
yeah pretty much this is so cool so I
guess that's it
I hope that doesn't freak you out no it
doesn't at all so diverse
save the body exactly I feel like she's
very conscious and aware about what's
going on with her body and with the
world in general trying to combine them
together makes her really warm-hearted
and also determined to make a difference
[Music]
Thanks go for it oh I also please the
gummies first they're good freakin gosh
the smell of it you can like really
taste the fruit here with you just like
mix them both in a bowl okay I'm gonna
go for the cookies yeah wow this is
better than I expected actually
if Bowl is if it's gonna be healthy it
sure as heck better tastes good
yeah that's true that's true okay I'm
gonna go for the chocolate later okay do
you want one of these yeah on the palm
trees I'm crisps you kidding me okay
I'll try to send it over be ready I'm
ready
I totally got it would you like a
chocolate chip cookie
I bet you straw or a Ferrero will share
I'm gonna go for the cookie oh you want
a cookie
hmm okay ready ready three two one blast
off you ready yeah and I'm gonna short
it this time okay last one if you don't
get this yeah I'm coming over there
myself okay
maybe I'd rail oh it was perfect
yeah that landed right on my hand snacks
were sweet I thought it was amazing I
thought he was well-spoken and kind and
darling
and like a great aim he gave me a
Parmesan crisp and like that's all I
could ever ask for
anyone pretty well I'm actually really
happy this completely expanded my vision
about snacks or like the perspective
that I had trying this and talking to
her a little bit it just made me realize
that she's for sure someone that you
like to be around I would love to go on
another date with Avalon if she's down
for it I think she's a great girl thank
you - I love your haircut Thank You
Sookie I need you sounded cute but you
look so cute - you already like dress up
like on a date it's a fluffy shirt yeah
it's so nice thank you
same to you purple is for royalty so
really it's a really nice compliment
so hey mr. Juan mr. King me how you
doing I'm good how are you doing I'm
good so I was just like wondering if you
wanted to go on another date or
something you actually took the words
from the mouth I really yeah I was gonna
ask you out myself
well you leave me to it I'll say yes
I'll see you soon okay awesome
[Laughter]
[Music]